you didn't grow up with mr. Rogers oh no
I was you were like a teenager I was too
old mr. Rogers Cena came on in 67 I was
11 years old I remember thinking are
these these puppets the mouths didn't
move right they were just I think are
they communicating with us
telepathically I'm King Friday the 13th
I could not get past the well you know
lack of animatronic quality - yeah and I
was all there I knew how the world works
so I was already cynical by the time mr.
I just was saying I think when you're
older and you're cut yeah if you're
already going through that like puberty
said you're like too cool maybe before
you kind of know how the world works
you know when you learn that they're
jerks in the world they're you're too
old for mr. Rogers I feel like when you
have so much negativity and then you
have something like that to watch like
that was so healthy most adults on TV
were trying to sell you toys or
introducing the Three Stooges not
exactly the mr. Rogers influence because
according to the TV shows i watch as a
kid you could stick a bellows in
somebody's mouth pump it up and they
would float up to the top of the sounds
fun - oh that's what I grew up on a
frying pan with the shape of curly Joe's
head I like both of those because I also
grew up on Lucille Ball I love Lucille
Ball was playing some are on TV right
now around I know it she's always on at
11 o'clock in the morning I Love Lucy is
on you do not watch it I think I can't
now the show's been on TV for 50 years
she's gonna rollerskate there's no
mayonnaise in like a newspaper boy I
know them all what do you think like is
too far like with a nice neighbor cuz
you want to be neighbors but at the same
time like it could go too far - you're
like you vote you've crossed the line
like I don't do airport shuttles if
someone says hey I got a I got a plane
can I ask you a favor George Wallace the
comedian had this thing when you got a
call from a for instance hey can I ask
you a favor
you knew what you were going to be doing
we're driving to the airport you were
going to take that person to the airport
it was all the matter what time and the
the horrible thing was when they
wouldn't do it for ya yeah if you gave
somebody to a ride to the airport
odhh you were right to the airport and
if you call them up and said times up I
need a ride to the airport and if they
had any excuse
off the Christmas list oh my god I'm off
the Christmas I hate oh you have a job
you won't be in town I think real
friends and real family do not ask you
to do airport shuttles that's love well
that's the other aspect of it well now
it's like uber and lyft said do you have
your own
I literally my sister came in yesterday
I was like yes I've got you a nice car
coming to get you I have two shows too
happy to give you a ride to the airport
for 47 dollars and a 20% tip and a five
star review you got me I'm right there
five stars
okay you have played real-life heroes
characters that are kind of based off of
real people like you've done some really
hardcore characters I'm wondering
because castaway obviously wasn't like a
real based off of someone you know but
it was a real circumstance but is it
harder to play the fiction when it's
like that or is it harder to play the
real I will tell you that when you play
the first player you play somebody alive
like I've you know I've played a number
really I like like yeah
I went to Sully's Howard to Sully's
house and he had the script with all
sort of notes on it so what does this
mean and how can you say that I said
look look look look yeah first of all
I'm not the boss secondly that's I'm a
gun for hire but understand this I'm
going to say things you never said and
I'm going to do things you never did I'm
gonna be places you never work it's a
movie but in spite of that I'd like to
be as a correct as possible and there
are things that you can like you could
end up sliding and like for example soli
captain so lethal there was there was a
scene in which me and Aaron Eckhart in
the play to the cockpit were having
chitchat yeah and he said you can't have
chitchat in the cockpit like that once
the plane rolls away from the gate you
are not allowed to have any conversation
other than with the tower or about the
flight and I found that out and I said
well if we just switch it to before we
pulled out it'll be okay so well yet I
want to say thank you so much for a kid
that group of mr. Rogers you did such
great job well thanks I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this